bueno ya sabemos todos que en la
derivada con respecto de x b el
logaritmo natural de x
o sea el logaritmo base donde este es un
número muy especial de clics es la
derivada con respecto x de el logaritmo
natural de x que es 1 / x
pero qué pasa con la derivada de
logaritmos con otras bases ya por
ejemplo qué pasa con la derivada del
logaritmo base b de x donde b es una
base arbitraria o sea puede ser
cualquier base y bueno como evaluamos
esto esto a que es igual y el truco está
en encontrar una expresión para el
logaritmo base b en términos del
logaritmo natural y bueno resulta que
nosotros ya demostramos en algún lado de
la página de khan academy y puedes ir a
buscar lo que hay una expresión para el
logaritmo base b en términos del
logaritmo natural y bueno aquí nada más
lo voy a volver a escribir que logaritmo
base b de x es igual a logaritmo base
de x que es no es nada más que el
logaritmo natural de x / logaritmo base
de b
y otra vez o sea justo a este término es
a lo que le llamamos logaritmo natural
debe entonces usando esta expresión ya
podemos sacar muy fácilmente la derivada
o sea nada más tenemos que sustituirlo
ahí y vamos a ver lo fácil que es
entonces la derivada con respecto de x
del logaritmo base b donde la vez
cualquier va a servir área de x es igual
a la derivada con respecto de x de pues
aquí vamos a dividirlo no o sea vamos a
ponerle 1 entre logaritmo natural de b
que por cierto esto es una constante o
sea la b es una constante porque es la
base y entonces el logaritmo natural
debe también es una constante por el
logaritmo natural de x el logaritmo
natural de x el cual éste si ya no es
una constante entonces como éste es una
constante entonces sale de la derivada
y esto nos queda igual a 1 entre la
constante logaritmo natural de b por la
derivada con respecto de x de logaritmo
natural de x
y esto pues esto ya sabemos muy bien qué
hacer no o sea hasta aquí lo escribimos
en la esquina para que no se nos olvide
entonces la derivada con respecto de x
del logaritmo natural de x es 1 / x y
tenemos que multiplicarlo por la
constante que sacamos o sea 1 entre el
logaritmo natural de b
y listo esta es la derivada
y bueno entonces ya sabemos muy bien
cuál es la derivada con respecto de x
del logaritmo base de de x para
cualquier base ve por ejemplo qué
pasaría si nosotros quisiéramos saber
cuál es la derivada con respecto de x
del logaritmo base 5 de x
ya ya tienen la respuesta
pues esto simplemente va a ser uno sobre
logaritmo natural o sea logaritmo base
de de 5 por equis y listo